assalamualaikum greetings a peace I'm
here with Akram ha ha
Huk from the sabirah halal market here
in Devon and he's sharing with me you
know a story about his father I'm gonna
let him go ahead and take it away and
it's the power of food the power go
ahead and share with us your father's
experience he was sick and what happened
assalamualaikum my name is Graham Cox
I'm here at the Diwan Avenue and I'm
hearing this with my friend here about
my father's life and our father used to
be I mean he lived to be 92 and at age
92 he used to walk five miles every day
in the morning and he never been to a
doctor regular doctor he tried himself
with herbal medicine curing his disease
he had for a long time and which he
cured by using herbal medicine and on
the other hand he after his diet on a
daily basis and he saw what fits in his
diet he used that he normally used
substance which has vitamins and
vegetables those kind of stuff he used
and he stayed healthy almost I mean up
to age 92 and we were very blessed to
had our father like that what kind of
what kind of food growing up with your
father you remember you you guys eating
your father eating Oh simple wheat bread
and the lentils vegetables and the gram
flour she used lot and fish he used and
mostly and that's it and one more thing
which he liked most was the goat meat
not the lamb God seem to be much leaner
than lamb so he had no further nothing
so he was he was eating real food he
didn't in this process jungle perfection
he stayed away from all the junk and
faked food he's obviously stayed with
the real food and actually we at the
back home we had a little area where my
mother used to grow vegetables and those
the homegrown vegetables and we used to
cook from there every day beautiful
that's it this is it getting out getting
on it we know the sugar is killing us we
have to protect ourselves in our family
and this gift this Amana that the
Creator has given us a las eat real food
you know the message is really simple
stay away from fake food Salam alaikum
peace be with you